martin est là michel david christian
dufour bonsoir pourquoi je vous fais ce
qui n'était pas avec nous aurait coûté
le résumé de la coronaire ce matin qui
en deux mots a dit que le racisme a joué
un rôle important dans la mort de joe et
c'est chaque one et du de la réponse
synthèse monsieur legault qui sera
adopté le racé systémique dit qu'il faut
qu'on lutte contre le racisme évidemment
parce qu'en 2021 au québec on peut
laisser quelqu'un mourir
parce que cette personne là est
considéré
au même niveau qu'un animal utilisé le
mot que vous voudrez là si c'est pour
nous rapprocher faisons le n'hésitons
pas à faire les premiers pas qu'on
appelle institutionnels qu'on
l'appellera comme on voudra moi je ne
voudrais pas tant qu'on s'accroche sur
les mots que
le fait de rater un rendez vous
important et historique
quand on parle de comment ça
fonctionnait dans les pensionnats
autochtones
c'était du reste si ce système qui était
toléré j'étais ministre de l'éducation
et ministre la santé j'ai jamais vu un
système qui parle d'en haut puis qui
demande à tous les employés de
faire de la discrimination
ça serait quoi la conséquence si
gouvernement disait on reconnaît là
c'est
pourquoi je reconnaîtrais une situation
qui quittent qui pose selon moins exacts
je comprends pauvre
monsieur legault blanc n'a pas tout ça
c'est long martin l'aca il a fait ces
définitions et même parler du petit
robert il ya dix il dit si ça ne vient
pas d'en haut si un ministre ou un
autorités politico administratives qui
ne commande pas comme c'est le cas pour
les pensionnats puisqu'il fait le
parallèle il dit ça c'est vrai à
l'époque c'est dur à ses systèmes et
messi aujourd'hui personne ne commandent
d'en haut ce n'est pas dur assister mais
qu'à son avis là je pense qu'on est allé
au bout de la logique et un martin de se
terminer il a maintenant c'est terminé
il ne le reconnaîtra pas essentiellement
parce qu'il peut pas savoir jusqu'où ça
va aller est ce que ça va y valider
certaines lois qui veut se réclamer de
cette notion là il ya donné sa propre
définition qui est assez simple beaucoup
plus simple que celle de la commission
des droits de la personne relatifs à un
système dans son ensemble
ce qui est particulier c'est que le
débat est de moins en moins c'est même
sur le terrain politique il est très
polarisée il divise
il ya les bons et les méchants ya six
ans pour il ya ceux qui sont contre pour
les autochtones c'est devenu les
carnations en fait de ce qui leur arrive
pour eux c'est devenu assez excitant
mais en parallèle je voudrais que les
discussions avancent quand même avec les
personnes autochtones bon j'écoutais
quand même ghislain picard alors est ce
que je dis là bon est ce que on va aller
plus loin si sûr que les autochtones au
québec ont été tellement victimes de
racisme que et pour eux avoir cette
reconnaissance là c'est devenu le pas à
franchir pour aller plus loin parce que
michel david c'est la question que j'ai
posée c'est que bon manifestement sur le
groupe il veut pas reconnaître il a des
problèmes lui d'autres avec ce concept
la crise est venue en prêt dans une
seconde lui aussi mais ça peut devenir
politiquement un problème et je parle
pas au salon bleu mais face aux
autochtones s'ils se mettent à ne plus
vouloir parler ou en tout cas ahmed
zabana grenache ça et d'europol non
évidemment ça être pas maintenant je
sais pas jusqu'où les menaces la plongée
comme ça que monsieur picard a fait vont
aller il ya quand même des discussions
qui sont utiles quand on parle de la
protection de la jeunesse les
discussions qui ont eu lieu sur la
sécurité publique je pense qu'on peut
faire un bout de chemin l'un sur ces
questions là sans nécessairement là
revenir toujours à la question de
ressusciter milk mais avant de marée
dans le paysage ya aucun problème le
monsieur legault a fait j'ai trouvé un
tout petit bout là avant ça c'était
juste des individus maintenant il nous
parle de groupes d'individus long en
gros si un peu on peut la faire mais
écoutez il ya personnes là qui dit qu'il
ya des dirigeants d'un système de santé
ou dans d'autres systèmes qui gagnent un
mode horde en disant bon des autochtones
c'est le service minimum c'est pas ça du
tout dans ces questions là car anne elle
a parfaitement expliquer ce qui s'était
passé à jade y est il ya des débiles
jugé dans le système qui fait en sorte
que les gens reçoivent un moins bon
traitement il ya des gens qui voient ça
et qu'ils ne disent rien et là est tout
le problème c'est monsieur legault on
veut pas de voir ça ne veut pas dire que
ça n'existe pas christian quand la
coronaire part justement de
l'accumulation des billets prenant le
cas d'un jo et ses chakras nadia il ya
eu les personnes à l'accueil les
infirmières il ya eu des médecins qui
est bien se sont accumulés c'est là où
des gens dit ça ressemble un système le
fait que ça ne soit l'escroc peut encore
parler d'accumulation de gestes
individuels à ce moment là je trouve que
le rapport de la coroner comporte deux
parties ayant une partie a en fait tout
est dit que c'est du racisme ce qui est
arrivé à madame et chaque fois nous
donne des démonstrations de ça l'autre
partie où elle embarque dans le débat
sur le racisme c'est un mythe je trouve
qu'on tend la première partie fait
l'unanimité par les très importantes
parce qu'on parle beaucoup du raciste
puis à du racisme c'est bon on peut pas
dire que on se met la tête dans le sable
à l'écart du reste autant dans la
deuxième partie je trouve que monsieur
legault était gentil avec la coroner
quand ledit deux visions bon et de sa
vision moi j'ai la mienne moi j'ai
tendance à derry plus à ce que dit en
fait paul st pierre plamondon que dit
que la coronaire est sorti de son mandat
moi je crois ça vous pousse pas ça le
rôle d'un corner un corner c'est de
regarder les fêtes organise ce qui s'est
passé concrètement dans ce collège s'est
lancé dans un débat politique ce n'était
pas son rôle du tout mais monsieur
legault comme une semaine peut faire des
différences mais c'est le goût
aujourd'hui vraiment sont autant était
bon ils avaient l'air de bonne humeur et
ça fait beaucoup bien dans ce dossier
lot peut tellement être pourri je pense
qu il expliqué de façon très simple
comme dit martin pourquoi lui trouvais
que reste justement on n'avait pas ça
par mois juste moi et que c'est un débat
sans fin mais ça nous amène à penser à
ça monopinion ça vous intéresse plus
avoir pu sont plus racistes mais que ça
comporte un aspect mystificateur qui en
fait cabourg beaucoup d'impuissance et
d'hypocrisie le principal défenseur du
concept suscite plutôt à ottawa on est
là dedans depuis vingt et ans qu'est ce
que ça a changé dans les conditions
concrètes de vie des autochtones sur les
réserves des réserves qui n'ont pas
d'eau potable si moi je croyais une
seconde que le raciste hey mec avoir
amélioré la condition concrètes
désinfectantes je serais pour ça et
comment ce fait il je veux finir
là-dessus que personne ne parle jamais
de la loi sur les indiens et en reste et
se donne apparemment pas aux normes
ersonne doigt par les autres personnes
personne je suis pas triste quand est-ce
qu'on n'envisage d'idées sinon de
l'abolir de la changer de la modifier un
tabou on parle pour les leaders
autochtones avaient d'abord à des
chaires pendant une campagne était pas
si lointaine mais je veux refaire un
jour venir sur monsieur legault
christiane faire autour de tapas que
martin je vous faire écouter où il dit
lui même il dit juste un mot dit la
semaine dernière j'avais vu cette vidéo
de du député qu'elle et puis j'aurais
pas dû être en maudit en fait il donne
raison à tous et analyse de toutes les
couleurs politiques de tous les horizons
qui ont dit qu'ils avaient passé le
moods mauvaise semaine la semaine
dernière on y croit c'était plus fort
que moi j'aurais pas du faso ces
contenus ce n est le décès de joyce et
chaque one man j'étais choquée de ce que
guirec et les avais dit a tellement
inacceptable
j'aurais dû garder sow pour -
martin
culpa sur facebook d'abord il ya une
panne personnes l'ont vu mais c'est vrai
mais recule pas il dit j'aurais pas dû
je n'aurais pas dû me laisser aller
surtout pas journée en fait que deux
choses à dire là-dessus d'abord le
ministre responsable des affaires
autochtones ian lafrenière dans le
corridor de l'assemblée nationale tout à
leur disais que ça eu des répercussions
sur le terre
ses déclarations son attitude de
monsieur legault a eu
un impact sur les conversations qu'ils
ont avec les autochtones sa malle était
alors ce monsieur le goût devait
rétablir sa la deuxième chose c'est que
remarquer qu'il a à nouveau fait part du
fameux vidéo de greg du député libéral
reculer qui mélange effectivement la loi
sur la laïcité la loi le projet de loi
sur la langue et le décès de madame et
chaque coin et c'est ça je pense que ça
incarne assez bien la crainte comme
monsieur legault de reconnaître leurs
racines systémique c'est à dire que ce
sont des lois importantes au québec et
peut-être que certaines personnes
pourraient faire des liens en fait y en
a qui le font déjà des liens avec du
racisme
est ce que ces lois là pourraient
éventuellement être contestés sur cette
base là oui ça c'est l'argument qu'on a
time chez david aussi reconnaît pour les
autochtones il va avoir une pente
glissante
c'est pas clair dans mon esprit les
étapes de cette pente
d'une passe monsieur leubou le
reconnaître que dans le cas d attaque
quand je vois mal comment il pourrait ne
pas le reconnaître dans le cas des
minorités visibles par exemple qui sont
eux aussi victimes de racisme et
systémique en l'occurrence mais monsieur
legault isi s'est excusé aujourd'hui
j'ai eu l'impression que ce qui se
faisait plutôt du moment où il y avait
dix qui le dispense n'a pas le moment de
parler de ça que du fond de la question
par exemple quand il a parlé du jour
férié pied dit ben non ça va nuire à la
productivité ce n'est peut-être pas le
moment de dire ça mais il pense ça
encore je pense et c'est là souvent
qu'ils le problème de monsieur legault
c'est à dire qu'il ya des choses qui ne
se ramène port simplement à l'économie
et ça c'en était une alors qui est comme
une gaffe politique qui s'en est rendu
compte mais je pense pas qu'il sait il
s'est excusé du fond de ce qu'ils
avaient dit cette excuse et du moment où
mais d'absence de contexte ce que dit
oui christian moi j'ai noté que s'est
pas vraiment excusé je pense qu'il est
sa france juste être plus tôt ce qui a
exprimé ses regrets c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose a exprimé ses regrets
et c'est vrai mais michel raison c'est
pas il n'y a pas exprimé ses regrets sur
le fond c'est sur le timing le contexte
est il bien fait de le faire parce que
tout le monde l'a noté la semaine passée
s'était déplacé ce n'était pas à la
hauteur d'un premier ministre est tenté
par la démesure on peut comprendre les
taux d'approbation de monsieur legault
sont tellement énormes qu'il faut qu'il
fasse attention par rapport aux
conséquences sont des boissons enfin la
reconnaissance de rester systémique
c'est ça serait pas magique ce serait le
début d'autre chose il y aurait des
demandes d' excuses des demandes
d'indemnisation des membres de quotas on
entrerait dans un tout nouveau chapitre
c'est pas juste sous les quelque chose
qui réglerait le problème plus leader
autochtone seraient tous contents on
entrerait dans un nouveau monde qui moi
ne m'intéresse pas du tout et je pense
que beaucoup de québécois sont pas
intéressé à ça oui mais est-ce que pour
apaiser les chefs des premières nations
il ne pourrait pas dire que utilise le
terme moi j'ai rien contre moi je ne
l'utilisent pas pas ça renvoie une
définition qui n'est pas la mienne il ne
va même pas jusqu'à dire ça parce que
les yahia logique là de nous on se rend
compte jamais l'actuellement crise hier
que ça change aux conditions de vie
concrète des autochtones sa villa il
faut pas idéaliser non plus les chefs
autochtones il ya eu des scandales qui
les ont visés je trouve que c'est comme
un genre d élite versus d'autres délits
moi ce qui m'intéresse là dedans c'est
le monde concret ce que j'aime dans la
proche du gouvernement de françois
legault c'est qu'elle est concrète et
ian lafrenière josé son bilan est
intéressant si on a peu désolant dans
cette obsession là sur le concept moi
j'en reviens parce qu'un important c'est
le raciste concret concret sur le terre
conseil des réserves au canada n'ont pas
d'eau potable
le problème c'est que tout le monde le
dit quand on identifie pas le problème
on risque de passer à côté de la
solution ou de remède alors si monsieur
lebon
continue à considérer cela comme un
problème individuel et ça va prendre des
thérapies individuelles pour régler le
problème a de toute évidence plus large
que ça en tout respect michel il dit pas
que c'est individuel et je pense que
c'est c'est eh oui de
systémique c'est un code du world
idéologique symbolique qui vient des
états unis on ne rien apprendre des
américains en matière de relation
propriété de son époque american d'anton
jour j'ai vraiment porter des concepts
américains dans ce domaine au québec
hockey
toute façon comme vous l'avez dit que ça
c'est un débat sans fin je pense que
ceux qui croyaient peut-être le rapport
de la coroner la faire changer dit
monsieur legault l'aï sac ils ne
changeront pas d'idéal c'est un fait
alors poursuivant il vous avait parlé
des sondages l'intérêt sans christian
écouter ce qui suit sur le goût avait
déjà dit aux gens me représenter mais au
milieu de l'eau demande âge mon âge feu
rock peut-être j'irai faire autre chose
au tennis et au non seulement il dit
qu'il va finir le deuxième mandat s'il
est élu mais pourquoi pas un troisième
on y croit
puis quand on dit disant évidemment à
l'époque je pensais que je serais tout
de suite premier ministre ait dix ans
comme premier ministre pour l'instant
les justes rhodes sud oui vous imaginez
qu'elle me présente en 2018 s'était pas
bougé réa pandémie donc j'ai d'autres
deux objectifs
alors martine la pandémie a tout changé
ma vision moi j'ai des choses à faire
douter j'étais comme un peu détournée
maintenant j'entends cette semaine que
60 c'est le nouveau 40 alors as contre
le soixante dix pour être le nouveau 50
mais monsieur legault dans une situation
où il s'est rendu compte que si il
laissa entendre qu'ils étaient pour
partir il devenait automatiquement un
canard boiteux cc c'est ingérable en
plus bas ils vont être obligés de gérer
son caucus de gérer son conseil des
ministres parce que il ya des gens qui
ont commencé en catimini à s'organiser
alors si si impossible pour lui de
laisser entendre qu'il pourrait partir
quelque part dans le prochain mandat
évidemment c'est les choses peuvent
changer dans la vie mais bon là il était
assez clair là dessus puis garder les
deux mains sur le volant jusqu'à la fin
je voulais partir il revient ces
objectifs de hausser le niveau de vie du
québec en tant que celui de l'ontario
qui s'est érodée revient à ses
fondamentaux à lui michel il y avait
fait cette gaffe la souvenez vous il ya
deux ans il y avait des stands qui
peut-être finirait pas le prochain
mandat y a personne qui a le goût de
d'élire un premier ministre qui va
lâcher un job un an ou deux après alors
ça il ya corriger le tir dès ce moment
là maintenant moi je pense que oui
monsieur legault a perdu perdu enfin a
été occupé à autre chose pendant la
grosse moitié de son mandat et comme
tous les premiers ministres il veut
laisser une marque et je pense que
l'économie le système de santé
l'éducation c'est des choses qui
tiennent vraiment à coeur monsieur
legault
et ça allait bien avant la pandémie
l'économie québécoise se redresser à un
rythme vraiment intéressant et je pense
qu'il veut il veut poursuivre sur
certains sur cette lancée là il corrige
n 10 ont une impression qu'ils allaient
peut être dommageable mais il ya un trou
devrait dans des choses qui veut faire
c'est clair christian ouais on en aurait
jusqu'à 2030
je laisse mes mais plus sérieusement
j'ai trouvé ça c'est qu'en dit la façon
dont on a parlé était habile aujourd'hui
monsieur legault ça contraste avec la
semaine passée et moi j'avais
l'impression que un premier du québec
que jerry l'a pas dit comme ça serait à
moitié mort sur le bord de la dépression
nerveuse or aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout ça le message est envoyé il ya du
québec bonne humeur n'était pas fait ce
geek j'avais continué donc le pouvoir
quelques par rejet nerfs je sais pas
trop mais c'est ce qui m'a frappé moi à
quel point il y avait un verre en forme
et de bonne humeur malgré tout oui il ya
des choses qui veut faire comme dit
michel martin et qu' il ya une
parenthèse obligatoire obligé qui a fait
qu'elio remis à plus tard plein plein de
projets on verra martin gascon celui-là
dans l'est est ce que vraiment ils vont
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'europe il n'ya
pas confirmer que sa lettre projet mais
ça va de l'aide webb a cessé le plan en
tout cas c'est le plan que je lui dis il
ferme la session parlementaire pour
faire un discours d'ouverture au retour
de la pause parlementaire ce qui veut
dire mardi le 19 octobre c'est noté on
sera l'un plus vous y serez sûrement
pour analyser tout ça merci beaucoup à
vous trois bonsoir et merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh